hello everyone and welcome to Game one
of the world Fisher random championship
this these are the semi-finals one of
the matches is the Magnus Carlsen versus
Fabiana Caruana and the other one now
Wesley Silver's is an opponent and as
you might know or maybe don't Fabiana
Corona Wesley so and the only problem
she qualified through online play and at
Magnus Cross and he is basically the
unofficial world facial random champion
last year he played a match against
Hikaru Nakamura he won 14 to 10 and so
he to this day he is regarded as the
unofficial world official random
champion so here are the four of them
will now brought out to see who is
really the strongest and Game one is
Magnus Carlsen versus Fabiana Kirwan
well game one that we are going to cover
so basically the matches are being
played with 12 games so first for
classical games then for rapid games and
then for blitz games blitz games are
three plus two rapid is 15 minutes and
classical time format is 45 minutes for
the first 40 moves then you get
additional 15 minutes but the difference
is there is no increment so a bit of a
difference but yeah I'm sure they will
get used to it very quickly so and also
I would just like to mention if you have
access to Norwegian national television
they are also following the players
heartbeats so you can see you know who
has what heartbeat in what situation if
you if you're interested in that I don't
have access to that so I'm not gonna be
mentioning that but if you have you know
you are welcome to do so so that being
said let's check out the game and also I
would just like to mention here they are
playing this game and you can see that
Coulson has a white chair maybe I can
even enlarge it a bit for you see Carson
has a white shirt whereas Fabi has a
black chair I thought it was a maybe
they just preferred it that way or maybe
Magnus prefers white chairs or something
but then I checked out to the game
between Wesley and maple and they also
have a white shirt and the black chair
so I guess that's at this sort of a I
don't know it's there by design no idea
what why it is so but just wanted to
mention that so without further ado
let's check it out
Magnus would the white pieces opens with
d4
Fabi plays f6 one of the few occasions
where you will see an f6 on the first
move but you know such things are
possible in facial random with E for my
Magnus with d5 by Fabi and now f3 just
creating a very nice Center we have c6
Fabi also strengthens his Center and now
push up the g3 just developing the darts
were Bishop to this very nice diagonal
also offering a trade probably not
interested for the moment as if he
trades well he is interested
he doesn't think Magnus will open up IDH
file for his rook because you still
don't know where you're gonna Castle
castling in in facial random is always
wild and I just also want to mention I
forgot since this is the first game
we're showing players are shown the
position they will play 15 minutes
before the game actually starts so you
have 15 minutes to study the game so
okay Fabi trades here with Bishop
characters Knight captures and g3 and
now Knight d6 just nicely developing and
here cross and goes ECAD force on d5 see
captures and c4 already opening up the
position the point is that for example
if you develop this Knight if you move
the Queen then you can Castle King side
but castling kingside in facial random
means that the King will jump all the
way all the way to the king side and
well then you can maybe place the rook
over to the C file and then use it for
attack Fabi on the other hand castles
Queen side and this means that well when
you castle inside the rules of castling
and fissure random say that the king and
rook will be on the same squares where
they would be if you castle in regular
chess so here basically the King
remained on CA and the rogue just came
from a to d8 so far B Castle queenside
and I'll just Knight to c3 by Magnus
continuing development if you go
characters here black will not capture
with the rook and all Knights the c3 so
it can kick away the rook push the pawn
and maybe grab the a7 point with the
Queen if you capture night at 4 and
their nature is going to recapture with
the knight so not something Carson is
interested in Knights the c3 and the now
Knight to c7 just keeping an eye on the
d5 pawn with Queen to e3
now a key inside castle is possible and
the D captures on c4
we have Queen captures on C on e7 by
Magnus and now Fabi gets a lot of
development we have night the g6 with an
attack on the Queen Bishop the f5 width
track and Bishop to d7 blocking we have
Queen to e4 getting the Queen out of
harm's way and now Queen to f7 preparing
to bring the other look into the game as
well and here call sand castles King
side which means King goes all the way
here so the King nicely castled rook ht8
and now Queen to g4 are putting pressure
well for the moment on some of the Kings
side pawns but this is what this game is
actually about with King to b8 unpinning
also keeping an eye on the h7 pawn and
now rook F to e 1 countering fabi's rook
on the e-file Bishop the c6 now
transferring the bishop to a much nicer
diagonal and rook a to d1 by Magnus far
betrays a pair of rocks here with rook
captures only one rook captures anyone
and now Knight to e7 putting pressure on
the Bishop on f5 and here Crossan goes
for a very interesting variation he
plays d5 so one thing the the move d5
does it that it allows the Queen to
capture the pawn on c4 which is
something Magnus is interested in doing
since he wants to start attacking on the
Queen side we do have castles on
opposite sides so it's basically gonna
be who's able to attack first but here
Fabi plays Bishop characters on d5 first
keeps an eye on the c4 pawn we have
Knight captures on d5 and now probably
Magnus was considering Knight captures
or Knight chapters but Fabi captures
with the Queen and he says I'm not
giving up the c4 pawn so here it's a bit
of a problem because you still you
cannot capture the night if you could if
you play rook captures her than just
Queen the c5 check you will lose this
rook
so not not an option so after this Queen
captures on d5 move
Magnus played Bishop captures on h7 and
this is just a wild like like Fischer
did against Spassky in the round 1 of
the World Chess Championship match so I
know I know it's a you know crazy to
create parallels between the two matches
but this is also basically again for the
official world
official random world championships so I
thought it was very interesting but okay
Bishop captures an h7 and g6
Fabia traps the bishop so what's the
idea behind g6 why Cannot you capture
well it's the same idea because a Queen
to c5 check allows some excellent play
for for Caruana
I would just like to mention the time on
the clock Carson is 18 minutes Magnus 27
minutes the problem with Bishop
characters is Queen c5 check King has to
move and now Queen tabby for attacking
the rook and now the rook you have to
pick the rook away from the e-file
otherwise if well if the rook is allowed
to capture the knight here then it's
it's not gonna work out the black wants
to play rook the g8 to trap the bishop
but if the rook is allowed to capture
the knight on e7 then it doesn't work so
first you have to kick the white rook
away from e1 and you can't go anywhere
after the e-file because then look to be
one will be deadly so you would have to
play rook to f1 and then just the Ruby
g8 and the bishop is trapped next next
move you're just gonna capture it so
here after g6 cross and goes Queen to e4
he offers the Queen trade here also puts
pressure on the night on e7 but Bobby
says okay Queen c5 check with King to
each one and now f5 again pushing the
Queen back saying you still cannot
capture on e7 if you capture on e7 I
just trade and you're getting checkmated
rook e1 the rogue do you wanna check you
have to block check block check and this
is mate so a lot of background
weaknesses for Magnus so after f5 across
and played Queen to h4 again putting
pressure still putting pressure on the
knight on its own but now it's a bit
different because the Queen from age 4
can guard the rookin only one if the
knight move so here you have to be
careful if you try something like Queen
e5 trying to exploit some background
weaknesses then Knight the f1 wins the
game for white now you cannot capture
because the Queen guards the rook and
after you move the Queen just rook
captures rook captures night and that's
game over it's just a piece down and
there is no mate because now there's a
knight on f1 so it's not not a problem
but after Queen to h4 v e goes rook to
d7 adds another defender here and
Carlsen goes
Queen to h6 now so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the best
move for Fabi
in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
paying attention as the Queen is no
longer on h4 therefore the Queen cannot
guard the rook on e1 so here Fabi played
Queen to e5 for review if you just want
to enjoy the show the Queen still cannot
be captured because of rook to d1 and
you don't have any good discoveries with
the night since the Queen is no longer
on h4 guarding the rook so Magnus has to
go back with Queen back to c1 and now
the point of fabi's maneuvering Queen to
g7 and the bishop is finally trapped so
Carson has to give it up you have to at
least take something with bishop
characters on g6 Queen captures and now
Queen captures on c4 so grabbing some
points for the piece and if course and
can grab the f5 bonus well then he will
have three connected points on the King
side which maybe will be enough to
compensate for the piece we have a story
about that a sex by Fabi making some
room for the king and now Queen to f4
just asking Fabio what are you gonna do
pinning the night we have Queen to e6
again offering the Queen as cause and
still hasn't sought his back rank issues
and now Queen to b4 again now guarding
the rook and now threatening to capture
the Queen because now you can capture
the Queen if rook d1 check you just
block with the rook because the Queen
covers the rook on e want so here
crossing is five minutes on the clock
Fabi fourteen minutes on the clock and
they still have to make the eleven more
moves to reach time control so here Fabi
has to decide Queen f7 that's not if
seven Queen f7 to guard the f5 pawn or
Queen captures on a2 and trade a two
point four bf5 pawn Fabi decides to
trade with Queen captures and across and
plays Knight captures on f5 you cannot
capture I mean you could capture back
but then just Queen a fake check picks
it up so it's not a problem king a7
Queen captures here and we have the
position that we discussed we're now
cross and we'll start pushing a lot of
connected pass pawns on the King side so
after Knight captures on f5 we have
night C to d5 first
attacking Carlson's Queen Queen to d4
and now again the
in the night with tactics if Knight
captures then you just get rook to e8
check King c7 so that's a seven king c7
and Queen c5 will be made you don't have
any squares for your king
so after Queen 34 Bobby decided to go
for a Queen to a5 he wants to get his
Queen over to c7 and well either have an
excellent score for the Queen or if
Carlsen plays Queen e5 check which he
did block with the Queen and offer a
queen trait so here Carson has to decide
whether he wants to trade Queen captures
King captures Knight captures only seven
Knight captures and start pushing the
pawns g4 h four and so on where he will
have a 3 connected pass bouncing on the
King set but still he's down a piece and
Fabi has two points on the on the Queen
side and at some point when this pawn
reaches a three Fabul will definitely
have a passed pawn of his own on the
Queen side so after Queen to c7 cross
and decides to go for the Knight
captures on e7 instead and okay rook
captures on e7 by Fabi and now Carlsen
again has to decide whether he wants to
trade down into this Queen captures rook
captures on c7 g4 for example rook to c2
you go after the siege upon H for root
captor Sun B 2 and H 5 so this is one of
the options but this is not what we see
in the game after rook captures on e7
Magnus decides to go for Queen tha to
check first we have King the a7 and now
Queen to d4 check so for the moment the
Queen's around the board and now again
Fabi has the option of repeating of
course he's not interested in repeating
a position as he's up a piece he could
play b6 decide to keep Queens on the
board or Queen to b6 Fabi goes for Queen
to b6 and now he offers a queen trade
concentrates he doesn't really have a
better choice he he simply can't keep
and keep an eye on everything his rope
is hanging the the queen is under attack
the b2 ponies under attack so he has to
trade here with check we have queen
capture Sun b6 King captures and b6 and
now rook captures on each seven Crossin
goes into the endgame where he has three
connected passports on King side no
pieces and Fabi has a knight and two
points so Knight captures on e7 and g4
Carlson starts pushing his pawns on the
King side and the time on the clock is
Carlson 47 seconds whereas Fabi has
three minutes
on the clock with King to c5 making room
for his beep on and here
Carlson goes for King to g2 it was a
tough decision to make
with few seconds on the clock whether
you need the King g2 tempo or do you
start pushing right away but okay cross
and decided for King to g2 we have a
five by five e Carson starts pushing the
pawns on the kingside h4 and now a four
and here both players have reached time
control move for he has been played and
each player is granted additional 15
minutes so f4 by Carson he he wants to
play f5 keep an eye on the g6 square so
maybe he can start pushing the h1 but
it's really it's really hard especially
since Fabi calculates precisely Fabi
here started calculating does he need
King D 5 is the king needed to keep an
eye on the three connected passed pawns
on the King set or will denied be able
to take care of them all and can he just
start pushing his own past pawns
so he played b5 it's not a passed pawn
just yet just to be clear and we have f5
by Magnus and here we have King to d6
here Fabi decided that the king will
should help out a little bit although
there was a very interesting line with
Knight captures an f5 but this is
something I you know encourage you to
maybe pause and try to figure out on
your own but Knight captures an f5 does
win here well okay Bobby goes King to d6
also a very nice idea
and now h5 by Magnus we have King the e5
and now h6 we have came to f6 and now
King to f3 so far we decided that he
will bring his King to help out with the
defense against 3-connected passed pawns
and he can always play B 4 + a3 it's not
a problem so before and now kink the e4
by Carlsen with a 3 and here we have G v
g5 with the idea of course that if team
captures then you can play B captors on
a3 captures and push the pawn here the
king will not be able to stop it and the
knight also will be unable to stop it
because the f5 phone covers the g6
square so here
Fabi just goes King to f7 and here calls
and pushes h7 so what do you play here
you could play a lot of
things of course a capri-sun b3 is one
idea but Fabi plays the the nicest move
possible he plays Knight to g6 and it
was in this position that magnus carlsen
resigned the game and yes this is a
classical game but no this doesn't ruin
his 101 game classical three unbeaten
streak because this is special random
this is not classical I mean it is
classical chess but classical official
random chess so it doesn't ruin his
streak but a very nice win for Fabi and
it's very interesting how how even even
someone like Magnus can grab a poison
pawn and you know it just doesn't work
out but there we have it you know it can
happen to anyone
so Fabi takes Game one i I believe
players will now have 40 minutes to an
hour I believe before they start the
next game then they have the exact same
position and then Magnus has the black
pieces in fish random it's always better
to have the black pieces because well
you get to see what what what can happen
before you have the black pieces next
game and you don't have anything to
prove your you're still playing black
even though it's not normal chess but
you know so I've heard
I haven't played any any serious visual
random chess but everyone says they
prefer black especially in Game one
so we'll see what Crossan does with the
black pieces in the next game probably
probably cover that if it's gonna be an
interesting game but until then I hope
you enjoyed this so I would like to
thank Michael Bogart and Robert Keefer
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as you
roll you can check to my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the European Championship continued in
the coverage of the world's fish random
championship and of course checking up
on your wonderful suggestions so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day